the king of like Hollywood climate
catastrophizing is absolutely Leonardo
DiCaprio This is great this is from
disclosed TV on Twitter uh La Dolce Vita
in Italy for visits to the countryside
for lunch dinner or disco climate
activist Leonardo DiCaprio likes to take
the helicopter from his luxury yacht
build report so look at that luxury
yacht I've never been on a yacht like
that you guys ever been a yacht like
that no we're going to rent a Reuben
report yacht and get out there so he
takes a helicopter he doesn't even get
on a little dinghy he could get on a
dinghy and take it so that he could have
lunch but no he takes the helicopter
which burns a lot of fuel and a yacht
Burns a lot of fuel and just imagine the
foods they are eating on this thing they
are all liars and they lie and they
cheat and they steal when it comes to
everything
[Music]
thank you